Jane what did you think when all this
film was unearthed and then what about
the prospect of telling your story yet
again to sit down with Bret you've told
it hundreds of times I'm sure you tell
it in your sleep
sometimes if needs be so so what made
this one special what made you say this
one I'm going to do well I was kind of
pressured into doing this movie I didn't
know the handprints on your bed well I
mean I said there being so many films
this is just boring there'll be another
one and what can they do to make it
different I thought the same thing too
when I know you did that's what makes us
you know compatible he didn't want to do
it either
he felt exactly the same so anyway yes
well it'll give more exposure to the
work it will help the conservation of
the Jane Goodall Institute you know and
so I agreed to do it I hadn't met Bret I
think he particularly liked me much when
we first met either well I didn't
dislike you I just didn't want to be
interviewed
yep again I think she sniff you out for
her for my first question was sort of
what you said do you get tired of
telling her story and she said depends
on who's asking the question yeah I did
say that anyway so I was I was told
there'll be maximum three hours of
interviews by this guy Brett Morgan whom
I hadn't met and we met was the first
time we met in Tanzania yeah so they
created this amazing house and there he
was do you think it was three hours of
interview it's not just one more shot
thing well it's a but she had that same
reaction which is James James people
would say though as well as Jane said
just used some other interview she's
already done interviews and as a
filmmaker like know it God want to do
our own interview anyway see I think the
thing for me and I know how you felt was
the stuff about your work
it's very second nature to because you'd
lecture on that all the time
this stuff about Hugo and grub and your
personal life it's not an everyday
discourse that's that's correct it's not
anyway what I should actually
say about the movie first of all clearly
Brett and I clicked in some way so that
I didn't mind being interviewed by him
and it was two solid days of interview
not three hours it went on late into the
night
and anyway right correct and so when I
first saw the film you know I've seen
hundreds and this is the only one that
has taken me as I watch it back into
being that young girl in the best days
of my life so it was very moving to see
it for the first time and actually it
gets more moving the more times I see it
I think also part of what meat made of
fresh is that the technology that's
available is available to us today in
terms of color Corrections and sound
enhancements enabled us to take footage
from six years ago and I think make it
feel like it was as intimate and
immediate as last week in fact you said
people had asked you where you found the
actress to play a lot of really
intelligent people ask that question
that the footage is beautiful and of
course the subject wasn't so hard on the
eyes themselves right and when you sat
down and Simpson lovely when you sat
down to watch all this footage the first
time were you just overwhelmed by what
you saw or did you immediately start
thinking how am I going to structure
this story well you got to understand
that the chimps there's a lot of
repetitive activities that they engage
in so there were hours upon hours of
them noshing you know eating food and
they don't eat with their mouths closed
so it was that was like days upon days
of watching that was brutal but you know
there's it's sort of up to 140 hours
writing I mean you could probably break
it down to eating right I mean I don't
it's your vacation be eating traveling
from place to place a little bit of nest
making rather a good deal of floes
mating behavior
so much and then and then you go and me
yeah and then Grubb coming along by the
way Grubb is in this room will will make
him come up later but not yet he's
somewhere here but so it was you know
but the arc of Jane had written one of
my favorite books in the shadow of man
which is what the movie was called for a
very long time so her she is an amazing
writer
so she she knows how to again she knows
how to cast her own narrative so as far
as that was concerned it seems fairly
simple I think the one major
breakthrough for us was arriving at a
point where we realized that if we were
telling a love story but it was not so
much a love story between a man and a
woman as much as a woman in her work
your work has expanded and your vision
is expanded from Gombe and the chimps to
- what is the message you take today
when you speak to kids when you speak to
general audiences well I left Gumby
because I realized that right across
Africa chimpanzees and forests were
disappearing and I knew I had to try and
do something to help them and then
realize the suffering of so many African
people and me clearly we needed to help
them in order to try and save the chimps
and then travelling around the world
trying to raise awareness and realizing
what we're doing to harm the planet and
you know this expression we haven't
inherited this planet from our parents
we've borrowed it from our children but
we're actually stealing their future and
we're still stealing their future and so
that's why I began this program of the
Jane Goodall Institute Roots & Shoots
which is now in 100 countries with young
people of all ages from kindergarten to
university and the main message is each
and every one of us can make a
difference every single day in fact each
day we do make a difference of some sort
and we can choose what kind of
difference we want to make and you know
when you get to be 83 I don't know how
many years I have left to do this sort
of thing so people say aren't you
slowing down
so now I have to hurry out because I
don't know how much time there is left
and if you give him gifts and one gift
was a good Constitution and the other
gift is communication and I have to use
them I have to and you know I look at
the young people now in these hundred
countries and they actually are changing
the world even as we speak
and we hope it's fast enough